Wszyscy potrzebujemy możliwości komunikowania prywatnych informacji bez obawy, że ktoś podsłuchuje. Ale zaprojektowanie
niezawodnego systemu do tego nie jest łatwe. W dzisiejszym odcinku Qiskit in the Classroom omówimy, jak coś
zwanego kwantową dystrybucją klucza może
pomóc. Witaj ponownie w Qiskit in the Classroom. W tej serii omawiamy tematy, które możesz napotkać na kursie
z quantum computing na uczelni. Każdy film jest dostarczany z interaktywnym modułem zlinkowanym w opisie,
więc koniecznie go sprawdź. Dzisiaj wkraczamy w dziedzinę kwantowej kryptografii. Kryptografia to nauka
o technikach bezpiecznej komunikacji. Jest ona niezwykle ważna dla wielu aspektów naszego życia. Za każdym razem, gdy używasz
hasła do logowania na stronie, wysyłasz płatność cyfrową, lub gdy rządy przesyłają wojskowe dane wywiadowcze – wszystko to odbywa się
przez jakiś protokół kryptograficzny, żeby podsłuchujący nie mógł poznać naszych tajemnic. Ale jest tu pewne napięcie: jak
zapewnić, że osoba, z którą chcemy się komunikować, może zrozumieć naszą wiadomość, ale nikt inny nie?
Historycy kryptografii wymyślili wiele różnych protokołów, by ich wiadomości były jak najbardziej odporne
na podsłuchujących. Czasem dwie strony chcące bezpiecznie się komunikować zgadzają się wcześniej na jakiś
kod, który mam nadzieję jest tak skomplikowany, że podsłuchujący nie byłby w stanie go złamać. Ale jak
pokazali nam tacy ludzie jak Alan Turing i inni łamacze kodów wojennych, nawet najbardziej skomplikowane kody można
złamać. Idealnie chcielibyśmy wysyłać wiadomości zaszyfrowane w taki sposób, że nie ma żadnego wzorca
i nie ma możliwości, żeby podsłuchujący mógł je zrozumieć bez posiadania tajnego losowego klucza, który znają tylko nadawca i
odbiorca. Ale wtedy otwieramy się na nową podatność: jak możemy wysłać ten klucz i być pewni, że
nikt go nie przechwyci? W 1984 roku Charles Bennett i Jill Brassard wymyślili
metodę bezpiecznego wysyłania klucza za pomocą kwantowych bitów, która jest teraz nazywana BB84. Kluczową cechą tych kwantowych
bitów, czyli qubitów, umożliwiającą ten protokół, jest to, że przestrzegają zasady nieoznaczoności. Nie możesz
zmierzyć układu kwantowego bez jego zaburzenia. Dzisiaj zacznemy od przykładu prostego kodu kryptograficznego. Następnie pokażę,
jak kwantowa dystrybucja klucza i zasada nieoznaczoności mogą umożliwić nam używanie praktycznie nie do złamania
szyfrowania. Szczegółowo przeprowadzę cię przez protokół BB84, a na koniec uruchomimy go na prawdziwym komputerze
kwantowym. Zacznijmy od gry, którą być może już widziałeś, zwanej kryptogramem.
Dostajesz ciąg pozornie losowych liter, ale używając wiedzy o wzorcach w języku angielskim,
możesz podstawiać jedną literę za drugą, żeby nadać sens wiadomości. Oto przykład. To jest
tajna wiadomość z prostym szyfrem podstawieniowym. Wszystkie R reprezentują jedną literę, M reprezentuje
inną i tak dalej. Jeśli chcesz spróbować rozwiązać to samodzielnie, zatrzymaj teraz film.
Okazuje się, że wiadomość ta była zaszyfrowana bardzo prostym szyfrem zwanym szyfrem Cezara, gdzie
alfabet jest po prostu przesunięty o pewną liczbę – w tym przypadku 9. Więc A staje się J, B
staje się K, C staje się L i tak dalej. Im dłuższa wiadomość, tym łatwiej
dostrzec wzorzec. Więc przy wiadomości tak długiej jak ta, szyfr Cezara czy jakikolwiek inny szyfr
podstawiający jedną literę alfabetu inną jest dość prosty do złamania. Bardziej bezpiecznym sposobem kodowania tajnej
wiadomości jest tak zwana jednorazowa podkładka. Przy jednorazowej podkładce możesz mieć inne przesunięcie dla każdej litery
w wiadomości. Musisz tylko powiedzieć przyjacielowi, jakie było przesunięcie przy każdej literze, żeby mógł rozszyfrować wiadomość.
Ta lista przesunięć nazywa się kluczem lub podkładką. Nazywa się jednorazową podkładką, bo używa się jej raz i wyrzuca.
Jeśli jest używana więcej razy, pojawią się wzorce, które mogą sprawić, że szyfrowanie da się złamać. Przy
szyfrowaniu jednorazową podkładką zarówno zaszyfrowana wiadomość, jak i klucz oddzielnie są tylko losowym ciągiem nonsensów. Ale
gdy je połączysz, zobaczysz tajną wiadomość wyłaniającą się z szumu.
Zróbmy krótki przykład. Załóżmy, że już stworzyłam i wysłałam przyjacielowi tę jednorazową podkładkę, która zazwyczaj jest zapisywana
binarnie. A następnie chcę wysłać wiadomość „I love quantum". Wtedy zakodowałabym wiadomość
przy użyciu jednorazowej podkładki tak. Najpierw konwertujemy litery w wiadomości na binarne. Każda litera od A do Z
odpowiada liczbom 1 do 26 zapisanym binarnie. Więc A to 0 0
0 1, B to 0 0 1
0, C to 0 0 1 1 i tak
dalej. A spacja to po prostu same zera.
Tak wtedy wygląda wiadomość. Kodujemy wiadomość, wykonując XOR między każdym bitem wiadomości a
odpowiadającym mu bitem w jednorazowej podkładce. Jeśli nie znałeś wcześniej XOR,
stoi to za exclusive or. XOR między dwoma bitami daje jeden, jeśli tylko jeden
z bitów wynosi jeden, i zero, jeśli oba są zero lub oba jeden. Więc pierwszy zestaw pięciu bitów zakodowanej
wiadomości to 1 0
0 1 1. Resztę XOR-ów zostawię tobie do samodzielnego obliczenia. Ale chodzi o to, że
ta wiadomość to teraz losowy ciąg zer i jedynek bez żadnego wzorca. Jest całkowicie niemożliwa do odczytania przez kogokolwiek,
kto nie ma jednorazowej podkładki, której użyliśmy do zaszyfrowania wiadomości. Czego nauczyliśmy się do tej pory? Niektóre schematy szyfrowania
są lepsze od innych, a niektóre mogą być wywnioskowane przez inteligentną osobę szukającą wzorców w zaszyfrowanej
wiadomości. Ale naprawdę losowy klucz, który przesuwa każdą literę tajnej wiadomości o inną losową wartość, nie może być
wywnioskowany, bo w wiadomości nie ma żadnych wzorców. Jedyną podatnością w takim schemacie jest upewnienie się,
że klucz użyty do zaszyfrowania wiadomości nie wpadnie w niepowołane ręce. I tutaj wchodzi kwantowa dystrybucja klucza.
Używając qubitów, Bennett i Brassard wymyślili sposób, w jaki dwie strony mogą uzgodnić klucz i
być w miarę pewne, że żadna trzecia strona nie słuchała potajemnie. Ten protokół BB84 jest nieco skomplikowany, ale
przejdziemy przez niego krok po kroku. Na potrzeby tego wyjaśnienia przywołajmy naszych starych przyjaciół, Alice i
WEBVTT
Boba. Protokół zaczyna się od tego, że Alice przygotowuje zestaw qubitów do wysłania Bobowi. Te qubity zawierają
informacje, które staną się ich wspólną jednorazową podkładką lub kluczem. Alice najpierw generuje dwie losowe sekwencje
tej samej długości. Jedna to losowa sekwencja zer i jedynek, a druga to losowa sekwencja x-ów i z-ów reprezentujących
bazę, w której przygotuje swoje qubity. Następnie przygotuje każdy qubit w stanie kwantowym zgodnie z
kombinacją bazy i wartości bitu pokazaną na tym wykresie. Więc jeśli bit wynosi zero, a baza to z, przygotuje
qubit w stanie zero. Albo jeśli bit wynosi jeden, a baza to X, przygotuje go w stanie minus. Jeśli
nie jesteś pewien, czym są te bazy i stany kwantowe – to jest w porządku. Główna rzecz, którą musisz wiedzieć, to
że pomiary w każdej bazie zawsze mają tylko dwa możliwe wyniki: 0 lub 1 dla bazy Z i plus lub minus dla bazy X.
Jeśli zmierzysz stan zero w bazie Z, zawsze dostaniesz zero.
Ale jeśli zmierzysz ten sam stan w bazie x, dostaniesz losowy wynik – albo plus, albo minus – każdy z 50%
szansą. Więc Alice może przygotować ciąg qubitów taki jak ten, gdzie tu jest losowy ciąg
zer i jedynek, a tu losowy ciąg x-ów i z-ów. Więc pierwszy element każdej z jej
dwóch sekwencji to 0 i x. Oznacza to, że przygotuje pierwszy qubit w stanie plus i tak
dalej. Gdy przygotuje wszystkie stany qubitów, Alice wyśle Bobowi te qubity, a Bob losowo wybierze między X
i Z jako bazę, w której zmierzy każdy z nich. Dodajemy więc kilka wierszy do
wykresu, reprezentujących wybory Boba i pomiary. Oto wybory i pomiary Boba.
Oto wyniki pomiarów qubitów, które Alice mu wysłała. Wreszcie Bob
może przekonwertować każdy pomiar na bit, używając tej samej tabeli, której Alice używała do przygotowania qubitów. Gdy mierzy
stan zero lub plus, przypisuje wartość bitu zero. Tam, gdzie mierzy stan jeden lub minus, wpisuje
jedynkę. Więc ostateczny ciąg bitów Boba to ten ostatni wiersz.
Zauważ, że gdy bazy przygotowania Alice i pomiarów Boba się zgadzają, ich bity też będą się zgadzać.
Ale jeśli Alice wybierze przygotowanie Z, a Bob mierzy w X lub odwrotnie,
odpowiadające bity Alice i Boba niekoniecznie będą takie same. Sposobem, w jaki oboje mogą uzgodnić ciąg bitów
dla swojej jednorazowej podkładki, jest zadzwonić do siebie i powiedzieć, których baz używali dla każdego qubitu.
Gdy bazy się zgadzają, zachowują bit, a gdy się nie zgadzają, odrzucają go.
Więc w tym przypadku Alice i Bob uzgodnią ciąg bitów 0 0 1 0
0. Jak ten schemat chroni przed niezauważonymi podsłuchującymi? Zobaczmy, co się dzieje, gdy taki podsłuchujący
o imieniu Eve przechwytuje qubity, które Alice wysyła do Boba. Nie wie, w jakim stanie są te qubity ani jak
Alice je przygotowała. Więc dzięki zasadzie nieoznaczoności i czemuś zwanemu twierdzeniem o niesklonowaniu nie może
po prostu zrobić identycznych kopii qubitów do przekazania Bobowi. Gdyby mogła, byłaby w stanie
podsłuchiwać bez wykrycia. Zamiast tego zgaduje bazę, w której zmierzyć każdy qubit, mierzy je, a następnie
przygotowuje nowy zestaw spreparowanych qubitów do wysłania Bobowi. Istnieją inne bardziej podstępne sposoby, w jakie Eve mogłaby próbować
dowiedzieć się czegoś o qubitach, ale żaden z nich nie obchodzi zasady nieoznaczoności.
Przyjmijmy więc tę prostą metodę podsłuchiwania Eve. Oto wykres opisujący
przygotowanie Alice, przechwycenie Eve i ostateczny pomiar Boba. Teraz, gdy
Alice i Bob rozmawiają przez telefon, żeby porównać swoje bazy, zdecydują się zachować te bity dla swojego klucza, ale
bity się nie zgadzają. Dzieje się tak, bo Bob mierzył qubity przygotowane przez Eve, a nie oryginalne qubity Alice.
Jeśli porównają podzbiór bitów w swoich ciągach, zobaczą, że niektóre się nie zgadzają i
założą, że musiał być podsłuchujący. Ponieważ Eve została odkryta, Alice i Bob wyrzucą
swoje ciągi bitów i zaczną protokół od nowa. Ale gdyby Eve nie słuchała i podzbiór bitów,
które Alice i Bob porównali, zgadzał się, mogliby iść dalej i użyć pozostałych bitów, których nie
porównywali, jako swojego wspólnego klucza. Gdy Alice i Bob mają wspólny klucz, Alice może wysyłać do Boba zaszyfrowane wiadomości,
a Bob jest jedyną osobą, która może je odszyfrować używając klucza. Teraz, gdy przeszliśmy przez protokół, wypróbujmy go na
komputerze kwantowym. Jest kilka rzeczy, które trzeba mieć na uwadze w tym eksperymencie. Po pierwsze,
BB84 jest naprawdę użyteczny tylko wtedy, gdy Alice i Bob są od siebie daleko. W eksperymencie, który zaraz przeprowadzimy, Alice
i Bob są na tym samym chipie kwantowym. Więc ten eksperyment nie będzie użyteczny do wymiany prywatnych informacji, ale to
nadal dobra konceptualna demonstracja BB84.
Po drugie, prawdziwe komputery kwantowe mają szum. Więc nawet jeśli baza przygotowania Alice zgadza się z bazą pomiarów Boba
i nie było podsłuchującego, jest nadal małe prawdopodobieństwo, że zmierzą różne bity z powodu błędów
w komputerze kwantowym. Porównując swoje ciągi bitów, żeby sprawdzić, czy jest podsłuchujący, muszą mieć pewną tolerancję na błędy, zanim
dojdą do wniosku, że podsłuchujący musiał się z nimi bawić i wyrzucą cały klucz. Teraz, z tymi
zastrzeżeniami, zacznijmy od eksperymentu bez podsłuchującego. Najpierw losowo
generujemy trzy różne ciągi bitów, każdy po 20 bitów. Pierwszy to początkowy ciąg Alice.
Drugi to lista baz, w których Alice przygotuje swoje qubity.
Wybraliśmy zero, żeby reprezentować bazę Z, i jeden, żeby reprezentować bazę X. Ostatnia lista to bazy,
w których Bob zmierzy każdy qubit. Na podstawie tych trzech list możemy stworzyć diagram circuit z instrukcjami dla
przygotowania Alice i pomiarów Boba. Wszystkie qubity startują w stanie zero. Żeby przygotować qubity w
bazie Z, Alice albo nic nie robi dla stanu zero, albo stosuje bramkę NOT lub X pokazaną jako niebieskie pudełka oznaczone X
dla stanu jeden. Żeby przygotować w bazie X, stosuje albo bramkę Hadamard, która przenosi zero do stanu plus,
albo bramkę NOT, a następnie Hadamard, żeby przygotować stan minus. Następnie wysyła qubity do Boba. Kolejny zestaw pudełek
w circuit reprezentuje pomiary Boba. Żeby mierzyć w bazie Z, nie musi stosować żadnych dodatkowych bramek.
WEBVTT
Po prostu mierzy, co jest pokazane przez te szare pudełka. Żeby mierzyć w bazie X, najpierw stosuje Hadamard,
a następnie mierzy. Uruchomimy ten circuit używając prymitywu Qiskit runtime sampler. Wyjściem jest ciąg bitów
pomiarów Boba. Następnie możemy porównać ciągi bitów Boba z wyjściowym ciągiem Alice, odrzucając bity,
gdzie ich bazy się nie zgadzały. I widzimy, że oboje dostają ten sam klucz.
Pamiętaj, że to jest prawdziwy sprzęt, więc od czasu do czasu może pojawić się bit, który powinien się zgadzać, ale nie. W tym przypadku wszystkie
bity się zgadzają, ale jeśli uruchomisz to ponownie samodzielnie, możesz dostać błąd. Jednak dopóki wierność jest bliska jedności,
Alice i Bob mogą być w miarę pewni, że nie było podsłuchującego. Zobaczmy teraz, co się dzieje, gdy Eve przechwytuje
qubity. Mamy teraz dwa circuits. Pierwszy pokazuje przygotowanie Alice i przechwycenie Eve oraz
pomiar. Następny pokazuje przygotowanie spreparowanych qubitów przez Eve i pomiar Boba.
Możemy uruchomić te circuits jak poprzednio, a następnie zobaczyć, co Alice i Bob dostaliby, porównując swoje ciągi
bitów. Tym razem dostają wierność wynoszącą 0,6 z powtórzeniem. To jest znacznie niższe niż to,
co można wyjaśnić szumem komputera kwantowego. Dochodzą więc do wniosku, że Eve podsłuchiwała. Quantum computing jest
dobrze znany i często wychwala się jego potencjał do rozwiązywania trudnych problemów. Ale kwantowa komunikacja i kryptografia
często przyciągają znacznie mniej uwagi, mimo że potencjał, jaki quantum może zaoferować w tych obszarach, jest równie
znaczący i ekscytujący. Dzisiaj omówiliśmy najwcześniej odkryty protokół kwantowej dystrybucji klucza, który jest
praktycznie odporny na niewykryte podsłuchiwanie. Jeśli chcesz spróbować wysłać niełamliwy kod z
certyfikowanym kwantowo kluczem, zajrzyj do modułu zlinkowanego w opisie.
Dzięki za oglądanie i do następnego razu.